welcome to this video playing cassoulet
from France let's see if or okay going
for a Sicilian what about what about
something else the e6 a 6-line count
variation yeah this is how they often
play it nowadays with them Bishop going
back here okay so he plays with c4 after
all c4 and f4 very ambitious set up what
about is this system is this a
possibility sometimes you can do this
not canceling quickly but pushing the
h-bond
really not i'm not an expert or anything
even remote to that in this structure so
what is he doing here if i go 90 for the
bishop the bishop saves itself Quincy
five and and might come or not okay okay
let's let's try that should see one
Quincy five the bishop is retreating or
not okay so it just gives me the bishop
which is certainly nice if I get the
dark squared bishop in this structure
can I yeah let's let's gain the space on
the way to g3 immediately here okay
prevents that so night h5 would actually
win the complete bishop pal I don't know
if this is a good good idea or not yeah
now I just have to trade Queens and I'm
winning but it's not so easy to do okay
especially when you don't really know
where your king is supposed to go we'll
see 84 be five I really don't have a
king position
yeah the h5 look is really funky
tending be fine yeah okay well I saw the
move but and I wasn't I wasn't sure at
all if this is good or not it opens up
my bishop here on b7 KarenT I'm going to
take you anyway so not making a big fuss
out of it so if I've he has 95 always
group chief 594 him yeah that's true so
if I've it's not a big choice so 95 SS
what he wants to do and maybe we'll do
queen here maybe so that's tough so hope
chicks I have to do that so up to five
ticks it's not a great idea okay
yeah I know that looks kind of sick but
v5s is not far away ok now be five and
then looks it too at the end
hmm how does he protect you too now I
don't see how actually
g2 will collapse definitely
Jim ninth XD six system I only move tool
to really do continue I think or not
yeah maybe if I was probably much worse
at some point here but it didn't change
really materialized and so take so
Bishop g2 is there anything better
probably not right Jack some has to take
it look cheeks or the other look the
other look is actually threatening made
let's let's read and check mate with
rook to e1 root g two and then maybe we
take that one or do we do I want the f6
pawn might make sense I don't really
know I have to be relatively quick about
things so 195 is maybe coming and night
c7 this is actually a threat time
morning in 94 496 okay I don't have the
time to calculate everything here
I would be okay to trade one pair of
rooks this would probably win relatively
comfortably yeah with rook edge to rook
cg2 would would trade one pair of rooks
yeah I can't don't you going to do that
just for check reasons of simplicity
check check yeah yeah the night it's
always tricky with the night white
person yeah I get a good room p3 an ad
for us it's very unlikely that he can
get a [ __ ] yeah that was probably
probably very very bad at some point I
don't know it looks it looks shaky of
this position so let's let's see hehe
gave me this this is this Bishop them
and Tre I definitely should be I think
somehow okay but it is difficult to play
and it's not my kind of position so I
went H form Queen here no I page 3 i'm
sorry not have six where the computer is
is without any mercy and why do we win
for example
yeah that looks really really
problematic now ok this was the way to
punish me he went Bishop e2 and here
also felt that this should be kind of
shaky computer is not seeing something
dramatically bad for me like 0.6 and so
on I mean it is not good but yeah I went
here yeah and this this is turning
turning the tide really because what
happened here is just bad for wine after
b5 he has to play Knight B 2 and this
keeps it at minus 1 something like that
and here I think it's lost right yeah
this is just losing giving giving the
exchange enter or actually ah Gucci 3 is
already has made this is made yeah it's
not so difficult right I mean the thing
is when you see something that wins you
tend to go for it and I mean it is this
happens to me when I don't have that
much time this is a winning endgame of
course but this is ending the game this
is made or ie or you can yeah what you
can do that but this is I even Bishop g2
is leading to a check made yeah i was
thinking that check check this is also
very convincing ok yeah but this is a is
a winning end game so check just nothing
to be particularly a um angry about yeah
that I did I miss that check as long as
you keep keep the winning position it is
it is ok oh ok well thanks for watching